الطلاق يمكن ان يكون له اثار دائمه على
اطفالك ولكن اثره يختلف بحسب الفئه
العمريه فتحت السن الثالثه قد يتذكر
الاطفال بالفعل الخلافات بين الابوين
عندما كانوا في الثانيه من العمر ولكن
بحلول الوقت الذي يكبرون فيه قليلا قد
ينسونها لكن هذه القضايا يمكن ان تسبب
مشاكل لاحقه
مرحله ما قبل المدرسه اي من ثلاث الى خمس
سنوات اذا كان الوالدان يتشاجران فقد يشعر
الاطفال في هذا العمر بقوه ان علمهم
يتعرضوا للاهتزاز وقد تتحسن الامور بالفعل
بعد الطلاق عندما يعود الاستقرار الى
المنزل وبمجرد وضع الروتين يمكن لطفلك ان
يبدا في الشعور بالسيطره مجددا
ان المدرسه الابتدائيه تحديدا من سن 6
سنوات الى 12 عاما يمكن القول ان هذا هو
اصعب سن للاطفال للتعامل مع انفصال او
طلاق والديهم هذا لانهم سيتساءلون عن
دورهم في الطلاق ويميلون الى جعل الامر
يتعلق بهم اما المراهقون فغالبا ما يكونون
متمركزين حول الذات وعلى عكس الاطفال في
سن الابتدائيه يدور عالمهم عاده حول
حياتهم خارج المنزل ومن غير المرجح انهم
يشعرون بانهم مخطئون في الطلاق لذا ياتي
القبول لطلاق بسهوله اكبر ونحن سالنا
الناس في العراق ما اسوا عمر للطلاق الاهل
بالنسبه للاطفال برايك نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
بين الخامسه والخامسه عشر بكونوا
الطلاق بين الوالدين بيكون سلبي جدا على
الاطفال بحكم انه صغار بيكونوا متعلقين
باولاده بعد العاشره خاصه دور المراهقه
يكون اكثر تاثيرا
لحالات الطلاق الصغير بين الام وبين الاب
كون ثلاث سنوات حدث ثمان سنوات لان هي
فتره اساس الطفل اللي هي تعلم عن صغر
كالنقشه على الحجر احنا المفروض ننقل
تجربه جاي يصير في اغلب البلدان العربيه
منها مصر اليوم ما تسمح بالطلاق اذا كانت
طفل عمره لا يتعدى سبع سنوات
والله انا اشوف الفتره اللي يعني هي اللي
تحسس بيها الطفليه فتت المراهقه من عشر
سنين الى 18 سنه لازم يعني يكون الاب
والام موجودين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات